I've eaten dessert virtually every night
for 20 years I have never skipped
dessert and I've been able to maintain a
six-pack for that entire period of time
I have done a lot of different diets
keto stuff I've done high carb I've done
low carb I've done high fat I've done
intermittent fasting alternate day
fasting carnivore style eating whatever
the last 10 years I've pretty much eaten
the exact same way be able to have
business dinners be able to have drinks
many of the entrepreneurs that I know
who've seen me eat and been around me a
long time end up adopting this and they
never go back what I'm not saying is
this is the most scientifically
researched whatever I'm sharing what
work for me if something works for you
just keep doing that number one is you
have to figure out what your goal is
either trying to get bigger you're
trying to get smaller from there you
start at number seven all the way up to
21 my videographers will put it right
here 7 to 21 and every three you go from
Extreme Weight Loss to moderate weight
loss to maintenance to moderate weight
gain to extreme weight gain all you have
to do is multiply your body weight so
I'm going to use 200 lb as my average
cuz it's easy with math so let's say I'm
a 200 lb guy and I want to get leaner
I'm going to go to moderate cut which is
the second from the bottom here of these
three which you've got 10 11 12 and I'm
going to say 10 cuz it's easy math and
so I'm going to multiply 200 which is my
weight time 10 which is this coefficient
which gives me drumble please 2,000
calories all right now if you're like
doesn't it change what about my exercise
and what if I have a physical job
doesn't really matter if you lose too
much weight too fast go to 11 you can
adjust it we've got 2,000 calories great
here's step three you multiply your
weight 200 lb again you multiply it by
one really hard math means 200 g of
protein some of the science nerd are
going to be like you can only metabolize
7 G per don't give a every pound of
lean meat white fish ground turkey
breast 964 ground beef shrimp whatever a
pound is 100 g of protein so if you need
200 g you need 2 lb and that's if you
exclusively ate meat I tend to eat over
my 1 G per pound I like eating protein
it fills me up I feel good on it that's
why I do it if you don't eat as much
don't now we're back to the math this is
the last math equation we're going to
have to do we have 2,000 calories and we
know we have to eat 200 g of protein all
you have to do is figure out what 2 lbs
of meat you want to eat or where you
want to get your 200 g of protein from
and figure out how many calories are in
that thing these 2 lbs of meat are both
turkey I eat turkey for both meals crazy
these are both 560 I know that that's
1120 that's how many calories I have of
protein that I eat in my day so I
subtract my calories associated with
those meals from my 2,000 in this
example and I would have 880 calories
left over those 880 calories here's the
magic of how this works you can do
whatever you want with them if you need
to go out to a business dinner you want
to have drinks cool well cocktails
probably 150 calories have two of those
and have a 500 calorie meal of whatever
you want because again you've already
got your protein you could just stay at
home and have an entire pint of ice
cream that's 880 calories or each of
these cookies is probably 400 calories
you could have two of them and that
could be your dinner it doesn't matter
and mind you that's with a cut that's
with me trying to lose a pretty
significant amount of weight now I
actually maintain cuz we're going to
this third chunk right in this in this
uh 13 to 15 chunk If I multiply my body
weight I'm more than 200 but let's just
say it's 200 for mat sake * 15 3,000
calories so I would have an extra th000
calories on top of that th000 if I did
that same thing instead of having two of
these cookies I could have like five of
these cookies for dinner or I could have
two of these bites and still have some
food I eat the same breakfast and lunch
every day I start my day with let's call
it a 200 calorie bar you call it a
brownie it doesn't matter if I'm
traveling I might not have this with me
and I'll grab a Quest Bar at the airport
right 200 calories and 20 g of protein
one of those bars and then I have a
shake and this is 30 g of protein and
160 calories I'm in for 360 calories for
my breakfast I got 50 gr of protein
knocked down already then I go to my
lunch I have a pound of turkey which we
already know is 560 and I actually only
eat half of one of these guys one cup of
rice I now have 150 g of protein and
1140 in terms of calories that I've
eaten so far mind you I have 3,000
calories to just to maintain all right
not bad so now I go to dinner dinner is
the big Flex meal for me
now I also tend to eat a pound of
protein at dinner do I need to
absolutely not do I want to absolutely I
love eating protein I feel good when I
eat meat if you didn't let's say you
were 150 lb and you'd already eaten 150
g of protein up this point your entire
dinner could be whatever you want pretty
cool all right as long as it equaled out
to the total amount of calories you want
and I do this also because then I'm full
if I just eat cookies I'm usually not
full this has worked for a very long
time I actually had a couple of guys
stop me and say dude you made this
nutrition video and like like I lost 50
lbs using it like thanks so much I get a
bunch of DMS about this stuff and so
this is really what I eat every day some
like where's your greens I have a
multivitamin and I continue to stay
alive and guys I've stayed away from
Fitness stuff mostly because like
there's all these armchair debates and
like I just don't care if you want I can
do a part two on how I train as an
entrepreneur it's different than if you
were like a pro bodybuilder or a
strongman or a powerlifter Olympic
lifter or just a normal gymrat I can
make that a second video put in the
comments if not just enjoy this one